hey good to see you again and before we
get started giving some love to the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by raycon those true
wireless earbuds that come in at about
half the price of other premium wireless
earbuds on the market but still crank
out that sound ray comes off for eight
hours of playtime and 32 hours of
battery life still fit in like so
actually pretty hidden by my hair and
they've still yet to fall out of my head
they remain my workout earbuds or
they're perfect for those days you're
just laying in bed and you know you have
to do that one important thing
listen to music a day worth living
there's also a built-in mic so you can
take calls and they offer a new modern
updated rubber oil look and feel as well
as optimized gel tips for that perfect
ear fit and they come with a 45 day
happiness guarantee which again i always
appreciate so click the link in the
description box or go to byraycon.com
exclusive deals up to 20 off your recon
order and thank you once again to raycon
for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it and now the biopic of
tennis legends venus and serena williams
starring will smith
so king richard like i said before is
the biopic of venus and serena williams
it follows the father named richard
hence the name king richard and his plan
that he had for his daughters to become
the best tennis stars on earth which i
mean will smith being in movies are
usually called the will smith show and
this solidifies the fact that you can
make a movie about tennis legends venus
and serena williams and it's still the
will smith's show to be fair to this
movie and its execution though it does
work because at the core of this entire
story is the family dynamic that's what
you see that's what you feel that's what
this father is working for and his wife
the entire family the parents are
working for that they're doing what
parents generally should do which is
make sure your kids have a better life
than you had right like that's the point
and you feel that you even saw that in
the trailer that scene where cps is at
their house and he's like oh you mean
we're hard on our kids just because we
are we're keeping them off these streets
and i love how will smith portrays his
character how the movie portrays the
character you know it's this person
who's he's a dad who undeniably loves
his family he's also a stubborn and
flawed person but you never i mean we're
all flawed and yes also stubborn he has
a hustle to him and there are a couple
times where i'm like dude if i were that
guy that you made that deal with and you
omitted that information i'd be pissed
you know i'd be pissed if i were dealing
with richard in that capacity but if i
were richard if i were the father
i also would have omitted the
information to make sure the deal
happened so you have all these
characters who are frustrated with each
other who are locking horns with each
other but you're like i kind of see
where you're all coming from because
that's just life and i thought will
smith was great in the role will smith
at this point he's like i've done so
much with my career i really want that
oscar so we see him doing a lot of
character pieces like this but he's
always reliably good at them will
smith's a great actor he brings the
heart into this role and you needed an
actor who could portray that because you
have an actor who brings that to the
forefront
you get it you know you get where this
guy is coming from and you get what he's
working for also he's a very positive
guy at the tennis matches you know he'd
be like oh good luck to you you know he
he's like a nice person you'd want to
interact with he's all about
sportsmanship he doesn't want his
daughters to be cocky he's like dude be
humble do the work don't brag and when
he frustrates john bernthal because he
omitted information he says it was such
a smile that bernthal's character has no
choice but to just kind of like
be frustrated but he can't hate him he's
got that smile the movie did a good job
of balancing all those elements of this
character but it's not just richard
anjanue ellis plays his wife the mother
of venus and serena williams i thought
she was great too this is one dialogue
that becomes a monologue with anjanu
ellis where she's talking about like
dude i've been here too i'm dreaming
along with you it's one of those
monologues you ever watch a biopic or a
drama and when a monologue happens
you're like yeah if this person is
nominated for an oscar that's the clip
they're going to use it was one of those
monologues i don't know if she's going
to be nominated for an oscar i just
don't think like the academy that's not
me but if she is it's going to be that
clip now cena sydney as venus williams
is more in the forefront than serena
williams is because she's the one who
got the coaches coach was like hey well
i can take one but i can't train two so
it follows venus more than serena
williams again though they used that to
their advantage i thought they were both
great in the movie because it's like oh
venus gets all the training but then it
shows that they take that training that
venus just learned and they go with
serena at home and she then practices
with that training it's kind of a two
for one but it's also double the work
which shows the fortitude of this family
and how much they wanted the best for
their kids but both sania sydney and
demi singleton as venus and serena
williams i thought they were both
fantastic they were both great they they
both brought the heart you want to see
you know it's like oh i mean they're
tennis legends they get to play tennis
legends and you're hoping like come on
be likable be good also be good actors
please and they were all of that they
were everything you wanted to see as the
youth of venus and serena williams
portrayed on screen john bernthal was
great in this movie too i'm used to
seeing him as the badass you know frank
castle this movie he's this really rich
stressed out coach who has to deal with
a father who's going against his advice
and he has no choice but to be like okay
i guess if you want to pass on that deal
because you think something
oh man i always appreciate it in any
capacity when an actor flexes their
acting range i thought this was a good
move for john bernthal and in the end i
love me a good biopic i love the formula
i love the execution i love seeing a
fictionalized version of what happened
hopefully it's as real as they can make
it for entertainment purposes and this
was a great biopic and it shakes up the
formula a bit you know it's not just
these girls have dreams and they achieve
those dreams keeping the family dynamic
in the forefront i thought was a smart
move it was a great move it's an
inspiring biopic seeing the beginning of
these two epic careers but also a
heartfelt film about family and love the
movie is a bit long you know it's
clocking in at around two and a half
hours or so it's hard to tell with
trailers these days
somewhere around there but i don't know
what i would cut like you can't be like
oh they should have shaved time here i
don't know it all seemed to work for it
you know it all seemed to work to the
end goal in which the movie did have
great payoff it was a great balance of
family being at the center but also
the tennis sport being that which orbits
that family dynamic and in the end you
have a great finale with an intense
tennis match i had me a heartfelt great
time i thought it was worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray it's one of
those movies if someone comes to me like
hey the family and i want to watch a
good movie after thanksgiving dinner
what would you king richard all right so
king richard have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you